meanwhile swiss voters have turned out
in near record numbers for a referendum
on the national covert 19 restrictions
after an unusually tense and hostile
campaign early projections show a
majority favor the current law only
people who've been vaccinated recovered
or tested negative are allowed to attend
public events and gatherings the law
also provides billions of swiss francs
in aid for workers and businesses hit by
the pandemic switzerland is the first
european country to put its pandemic
measures to a public vote
for more let's bring in journalist joe
fay in bern she works for the
international service of the swiss
broadcasting corporation joe it's
looking like current measures have the
majority support there what do you make
of the preliminary result
um well it's as predicted but of course
i think it's a big relief for the
government the majority of political
parties here and the majority of the
voting population as well it looks like
roughly 63 of voters supported this
issue
they're really giving the stamp of
approval to a change in the law that's
already been made so i think this shows
where public opinion stands and it will
also allow the decision makers to make
future changes with more confidence
really um the most controversial part of
this vote has been the covid certificate
and as you mentioned in the introduction
there that we've seen some really loud
sometimes violent protests against this
and now we can clearly see that the
majority of people in switzerland do
support this certificate
tell us a bit more about the coronavirus
situation in switzerland overall and the
restrictions that are in place at the
moment
um
well we still have masks in public
places on public transport in lots of
shops for example but case numbers have
been rising very sharply they're up 43
percent on last week and we started to
see the situation change quite rapidly
now lots of companies have reintroduced
work from home recommendations for
example
and a few days ago some cantons changed
some of the rules uh reintroducing masks
in some indoor spaces or in schools for
example and because of the federal uh
situation in switzerland it's the
cantons who would make changes first the
government is quite reluctant to
introduce national measures
so those rules looking to stay in place
for the moment joe faye and bern thank
you very much
france's minister for overseas
territories is on his way to martinique
in guadalupe following days of violent
protests on the caribbean islands the
french government has vowed a firm
response to the unrest local opposition
to covert 19 measures imposed by paris
is adding to long-standing grievances
over representation and living standards
the smoldering aftermath of a gas
station set on fire by protesters in
martinique
an attack that could have been deadly
there are people around here who don't
want to be killed
i don't know what these kids are
thinking setting a gas station on fire
like a bomb that's going too far
martinique and guadalupe have been
gripped for days by heated clashes
between protesters and police
the protests are being fueled by
opposition to france's coronavirus
policies including mandatory vaccination
for health care workers
martinique and guadalupe are both
overseas departments of france
administrative units subject to the same
laws governing the mainland
paris has already pushed back its
deadline for the island's healthcare
workers to be vaccinated
but for many the issue is a reminder
they have limited say over their own
affairs
directly to emmanuel macron
trade unions on the islands have also
been on strike over inequality and
living conditions
france's minister for overseas affairs
has suggested greater autonomy as
something that paris would be willing to
consider
you